All right, guys, welcome to the call.
I've got my notes over here.
There's a couple things.
Let me move this onto my screen here.
There's a few things I want to just make sure to cover really, really quick.
Let's see.
Okay.
Two things I want to cover quick.
Then I'm going to have Mr. Zach Palcomano talk about hiring.
We're going to be talking about how leverage, how to scale through hiring, okay?
How to duplicate yourself and actually build a business that you don't have to be a slave
to, okay?
So, number one, I was looking yesterday through the ... I was going through the training
yesterday myself.
Some of you guys know, or most of you guys should know, I am in the process of redoing
the training and not just reshooting the training, but redoing the way that we do this training,
the way that the whole experience, the way that we hold everyone accountable, the way
that we track out the progress of everybody, the way that the content is delivered.
I'm really, really excited about it, and it's ironic because the way that we planned on
doing it seemed kind of outside the box, and it seemed a bit weird because I hadn't seen
anybody do it, and I got to give credit to Aaron because Aaron's the one that initially
came with the idea, and then I was like, okay, I'm with you, even though it's not the way
that anybody I've seen is doing it, none of the big guys that whatever.
And then, I had ... there's somebody I really, really respect that has a very, very expensive
program, a $30,000 plus program, and I found out they're using this exact same kind of
system that we're going to be using, so I'm very, very excited, and just before anyone
asks, because I know you guys are excited, it's going to be out sometime in quarter one,
okay? Now, I'm not sure. I'm giving myself those three months just so that I have proper time.
I don't just want to fling something out. I want to have this thing be proper, so that's the goal.
That means that it could come out the last day of March. It also could come out sometime in
January. It could come out sometime in February. My goal is to get it done as quickly as possible,
as well as make sure that it is properly done. So, for those of you that are sitting there going,
I'm going to wait until version 3.0. Guys, there is going to be nothing in version 3.0
that is going to be some magic bullet that's going to make you a millionaire, okay?
There are people in this group, aka Ryan Dalton, that have used the information that is here right
now. That is, he's at $87,000 per month. There's another person I want to give a shout out to
really quick, Mr. Drew Wolber, who messaged me yesterday. We were talking, and he sent me a
screenshot of his, I think it was his Stripe account. He is approaching $50,000 per month,
and he just started. I was like, how did Drew join? I went in, I looked, he joined just over
a year ago, okay? So, for anyone sitting there going, oh, there's nothing missing. The training
is the same training, exactly what I used to get to Seven Figures. It's what Ryan's used to get the
Seven Figure run rate. It's what Drew used to get to $50,000. It's what Juan Finesse used to get to
$40,000. It's what Mike Veas used to get to $40,000. There's nothing missing, but I am excited to give
you guys something and deliver it differently that's outside the box, that's going to be a bit,
it's going to be a breath of fresh air. So, I just don't want you guys to sit around going,
I'm going to wait until the next one. No, go get some money. Go make some money right now. Go get
deals. Don't take your foot off the gas right now. It's December, but this is the perfect time
to put your foot on the gas, stomp on some throats, and go make some money, okay?
That said, I was looking at the training yesterday as I was going through version 2.0,
and I was looking, and we have our core training, which is digital landlords, which is how to get
the deal all the way to the sales FAQ, the ads FAQ, and then how to build the website, how to
rank the website, all of the technical stuff, okay, which we're going to be adding a lot more
information to on version 3.0. And I remembered that we have this other section called the premium
sales training library, which obviously I, of course, always knew that because I have a little
reminder for myself every week or every month to try and add new content to that as much as possible.
And I realized out of the 700 people, whatever, only 200 people, 220 or something people are
actually have access to the premium sales training library. So if you want, let me just
tell you this really quick. The premium sales training library is a compilation. It's not
done yet. It's ever evolving. It's ever being added to. It's something that I've started
creating and having a lot of fun with. This is 10 years of sales experience
in distilled into a training. Okay. And there's multiple videos. There's going to be more
content added to get access to the premium sales training library. You need to be paid in full your
tuition, the cost of entering this program. Some of you guys joined when we were still doing
internal payment programs or you guys use other funding sources. You need to be paid in full
with me. And if you are, you get access, you are granted access. You have the right to access
this premium sales training library, but it's shocking because less than a third of the people
in this program have access to the premium sales training library. And I know that there's
way more, probably double or double and a half that have paid in full. So if you guys have paid in full
message Aaron or fix it Felix and get access to the premium sales training library. If you have
not, and you would like access to it, go and get paid. What I was going to let you guys know is
right now it's December 3rd. There's 28 days left in the month. And anything like if you were to go
and you had like a thousand bucks left, anything that you do spend on this, because you're going
to spend it anyway, you can actually write it off as a tax write off. I don't know if you guys
understand this, but you can write it off as a tax write off. They can give you a break on your
taxes. So if you guys are people that are on like a payment plan, just get it paid off and write it
off on your taxes and get access to the premium sales training library, quit kicking the can down
the road. Okay. So that is going to be continually added onto that is 10 over 10 years. It's 11 years
of knowledge right here in my brain that I'm trying to put into a mini course that's ever evolving,
ever changing, ever being added onto. And as part of this program, as long as you are paid in full,
that is the premium sales training library. So if you do not have access and you are paid in full,
then reach out to Aaron. And if you are not paid in full, get freaking paid in full,
get access to everything and go and check it out. Secondly, for those of you that have not
started playing around with the rank and rent engine tools, no problem. You don't have to use
it. It's, it's not required. It's not something that you have to have. I will tell you that based
on, I know Ryan came on last week. I was traveling coming back from Dubai. And so thank you, Ryan,
for doing that. But we are so cool because we get to control this tool. We like literally as we,
my team goes through it, Francesca will go through the tool and she's like, Hey, I think
that this little button needs to be put over here to make it easier to drop down the menu and do
this. And I'm like, awesome, put it in a document, put it in a loom, send it to Ryan. And every single
week, every single five days we're sending a loom to Ryan. He's like noted and he goes in,
he talks to the developer and we're changing it. So we get to literally build this tool as we go
and we get to add into it. One of the things that I really, really wanted to see, and I talked to
Ryan about is like, dude, we got to make sure that there's a better, more in-depth way to look at
backlinks, right? And of course we wanted to come out with version 1.0 as soon as possible, as long
as the product was good enough. And we did. And I said, and we're going to have, you know, our tool
right now, it'll tell you how many backlinks, it'll tell you domain authority, a few different
things, but it doesn't really give you the backlink profile in depth. We need something that's at
least of the caliber of mangled. So talk to Ryan, he talked to the developers and we are right now
adding a backlink feature that's going to be as good as mangles right inside of the tool, the same
tool that's going to be your CRM, the same tool that's going to be your due diligence, the same
tool that's going to do everything. And I'm super, super excited about it. So that said guys,
guys, if you haven't already, if you haven't heard this, RankinRanEngine is going to be our go-to tool,
version 3.0. All of our training is going to have RankinRanEngine. We're going to be using
RankinRanEngine to do the search, the search volume. We're going to be doing RankinRanEngine
to do the, you know, check out our competitors, look at their backlink profiles. And if you have
not already, check that out. Now there is a code. Ryan sent it to me yesterday and I don't know
where it's at. Let's see here. Okay, here's the code for those of you. Also, by the way, for those
of you that are not in the U.S., that is our next thing that we're looking at is how do we get this
into as many countries outside of the U.S. as possible. So just so you have an idea, we are
working on that now. So I'm going to drop the code really quick and then let's get into this call.
And I don't know where it's at. Here's the code. Well, actually, you know what? You guys message me.
If you guys are interested in RankinRanEngine, message me. I'll send you the code and that's
going to give you a little discount for the first couple months to check out that tool. But anyway,
I'm having so much fun with that tool. I'm doing everything inside of it. I'm not, we got rid of
SEMrush. We got rid of Mangools. We got rid of every single thing. Ahrefs, whatever. We have a
suite of tools. We're paying 300 bucks a month, something like that, just for like basic tools.
And now everything's in one little place. Okay. So that said, guys, that's all I wanted to cover.
We got Richard Martez on. We got Ritu on. We've got Shane Noble. We've got, let's see, Eric already
said hi to Eric. Kirk, no, AiraRare is not available in the UK yet, but we are coming.
We are coming. Let me let Zach in really quick. And as I do that, let's see one second. Freaking
cold in here today. Zach Powell. What's up, Nick? How's it going, man? It's going great, bro. I'm
freezing. I'm going to turn up my heat a little bit while you give yourself a little intro. Give
me about 10 seconds, dude. I'm dying. Hold on. Sounds great. Yeah. I'm excited to be on today.
He said quick intro. I joined Digital Landlords two years ago and now I just love helping people
grow their businesses. So that's what I'm about. Today I'm going to talk about leverage,
which I'm stoked on. I've created a ton of leverage through hiring and building a team.
So great topic for today. I'm stoked. Yeah, bro. Appreciate you being on.
Always a treat to have Zach Powell on. Zach, what's your latest revenue, Mark? I know last
time we talked, it was just over 50,000. Yeah, we're at like 57,000. But there's other,
there's like a ads kind of arm we're adding on to. And so, yeah, it's maybe all together 65 or so.
Amazing. Okay. 65,000. Not bad for somebody who was making just around $6,000 two years ago at a
job. Yeah. Big difference. Yeah, that's crazy, bro. Big difference. How's the new house, dude?
You still enjoying it? Yeah, we call it the office because it's like a house that we work
out of like some team members in the US. We all just come to this house on an acre and
it's like catching the back and then work out of the house. It's fun. That's cool. What was I going
to ask you? Let's see. Oh, did you end up getting rid of the office office since you moved into the
house? Yeah, we were just renting that. So now we own this like acre kind of house office setup.
That's cool. Pretty, pretty fun. I remember when I first moved to St. George here, I was living in
Cedar City and it was cold and I came down, we're looking at houses and there was this guy, we went
and looked at this house and we went through the garage and he had like all these cars out front.
We went through the garage and he literally had like cubicles set up in his garage and he had like
his entire, he's like an engineer architect. He had like a 10-man team in his garage with fans
and the whole thing. Dude, I thought it was the coolest thing ever. I was like, bro, this guy,
this cat's like literally working out of his house. This is foreign, by the way. This isn't now,
like everyone works out the house now, but back in the day when you've knew somebody that worked
from home, it was like, you know, it was really cool. It was like unattainable. So it's exciting.
But yeah, dude, that's what's possible. I was on yesterday before we get into it and I was like,
I just jumped on really quick. I was looking at my goals and it reminded me like, dude, your whole
life, and this is a reminder for anyone on this call, that your entire life can change in a year.
Like you put your head down and you focus on one thing and you grow it and your entire life can
change in a year. You can go from barely making it, you know, budgeting what vacations are going on
to being able to buy properties, you know, buy your wife whatever car they want, get into a new
house and like your whole identity changes. So it's exciting because we have the tools
in front of us to do that. It's just up to us now. So one of the things that is part of this
business that I wish I had done way sooner was create leverage because I was Mr. like,
you know, solopreneur, do it myself, figure everything out on my own because I could beat
my chest, whatever. And then I realized that the real players, the people that are actually scaling,
they are using other people because there's different types of leverage. Zach's going to
talk about this today, but one of those pieces of leverage is human capital and using other people.
And so everyone, not everyone, but I get some messages sometimes like, when do you recommend
hiring? Okay. And that's one of the things I'm going to ask Zach, his opinion on this. My opinion
is as soon as possible. Okay. So anyway, that said, Zach, I'm going to give you a co-host. That way
you can share anything you want, but we're going to be talking about hiring, creating leverage.
And that is something Zach has done very, very well. It's allowed him to go. Where was it? You
were just on a surfing trip. Was that in Hawaii? No coaster. I was in Hawaii, Hawaii for a month
and then Nicaragua for a week. And then actually this last weekend, they opened a manmade wave,
like 10 minutes from my house in Arizona. And so I was surfing that on like their VIP opening day.
And it was awesome surfing in the desert in Arizona. So that's surfing across the globe,
man. It's, it's been fun. That's amazing, bro. I love that. And that's, that's,
that's the beauty of the business. All right, bro. You got, you got hosts. Let's, let's get into it,
man. You, I'm going to, rather than me direct this, I'm going to have you direct it because
you're the expert and I'll just kind of chip in where I see fit. Sounds great, man. So yeah,
talking about hiring, I think first it's a mindset thing we got to get over. Like you mentioned,
so I'm going to get into that. I'll share my screen, how I think about hiring and then also
share like how I actually do hiring and kind of my playbook for that. So let me share my screen
and I'll walk you through how I think about it.
All right. We good. You guys see this? I can see a white, yeah, a whiteboard.
Whiteboard. Okay. Here we go. If you guys have like journals or notes, like you're going to want to
write this down. It's pretty awesome stuff. That's opened my mind a lot. So the first one,
there's three things I'll show you real quick. And then I'll stop sharing, but the first one
to talk about real quick, it's called your buyback rate. And this will open your mind a lot. Buyback
rate. What is buyback rate and how do you calculate it? So essentially the reason we want our buyback
rate is you want to grow a company that you don't grow to hate. You want to grow a company that you
enjoy running. And so you don't want to hire, to actually grow your business. You want to hire,
to buy back your time. And I'll explain what this means, but the first step is calculating your
buyback rate. So buyback rate, the first thing is your income. This is like, if you have a job right
now, that income counts and the income from your business and all the write-offs that are like
for you. Basically all the money you have, like you guys know what I'm talking about when
you're buying things, you would have bought in any way, but you buy through your business.
All of the income, all of the financial gain you receive from your job, from your business,
from everything goes into your buyback rate. So income divided by 2000 hours. Why 2000 hours?
2000 hours because there's about 50 working weeks in the year, 40 hours in a week. That equals 2000
working hours in an average year. So divide your income by 2000 hours. That gives you what
your time is worth per hour, dollars an hour. One of the biggest issues with hiring is people don't
think their time is actually worth what it's worth. And so they're doing $5 tasks when their
time is worth $100 an hour. And it just absolutely makes no sense. And so this will help it kind of
become clear for you guys. So let's just use an example. Let's say your income with your W-2,
your job, your company, like everything, whatever. Let's say it's 100,000. 100k divided by 2000 hours
that equals $50 an hour. We'll just use that an example. So your time is worth $50 an hour.
And so are you valuing your time at that rate? So that's the first piece. Then you take what
your time is worth per hour. And guys, figure this out right now. Look at the past 12 months.
Calculate what your income has been the past 12 months. Divide that by 2000 hours. Get your
buyback rate right now. Once you have what your time is worth per hour, then you take that $50 an
hour divided by four. That would be $12.50. Why divide by four? Because $12.50 is what you can hire
somebody for and get a four times return on your investment. So if you hire someone for $12.50 an
hour or less, you automatically have a four times return on your investment if they take things off
your plate, if they do things that you would have done. And that's the key. So in this example,
let's say this person makes $100,000 a year, their buyback rate is $12.50 an hour. And so like
when I first did this, it kind of blew my mind. A couple years ago, I calculated this and I was
like, Whoa, my buyback rate is over $30 an hour. And then I looked at what I was doing each day.
And I was like, why am I doing $5 an hour tasks when my time is worth over $30 an hour?
It doesn't make sense. So sometimes we got to see. Go ahead. So anything, just to clarify,
so anything that is, just explain again, the $12.50. So anything that's less than that,
you should be hiring out. Explain that piece. Once you calculate your buyback rate,
what does that mean? And what should we do with that information? Because I saw a few
people that just jumped on. Awesome question. So basically, anything you do that you can pay
someone $12.50 or less to do, pay them to do that. Get that off your plate, buy back your time.
And this will go into the next piece here. That's an awesome question. The next piece
is the time and energy audit. So this is step one. Step two is the time and energy audit. And then
we'll go to step three. So step two answers that question in depth really well. So I'll just hop
right into that. We'll do the next thing, time and energy audit. This one's pretty simple,
but profound as well. Time and energy audit. Okay. So hopefully you've calculated your buyback rate.
If you just hopped on, it's your income, everything, all the money that comes to you,
your job, your business, perks, everything, all that. What's the number? Your income per year
divided by 2000 hours, 2000 working hours in a year, gives you your hourly rate,
what you're worth per hour. Divide that then by four. And that is your buyback rate because
you're getting a four times return on your investment. If you hire someone for a fourth
of what you make per hour, you're automatically getting four times return on your investment,
which is awesome. So next question is like, how do I find the things to take off my plate?
Well, this makes it simple. You just do a time and energy audit. So you write down the task
that you're going to do and you write down the value. And what I do on my watch,
I'll pull up and I'll say, Hey, like, you know, start a 15 minute timer and I'll just refresh
it all day. And every 15 minutes I have my running list and I just write down what I did.
Right. So let's say, um, drive to office there that, and then I do a value,
just $1 sign to $4 signs, $4 signs. If it's super valuable, $1 sign. If it's low value
drive to office. Okay. We'll say that's $1 sign. And then, you know, I get to office
deck email, you know, not that valuable $1 sign. And then I do a sales call sales call.
That is like the most valuable thing I do. That is the most valuable thing. And then I train my team,
team training, and that's valuable. Maybe we'll say $3 signs. Right. So from here,
then what you do, the other piece of this is does it. So it's time and energy audit. You're
auditing your time every 15 minutes. Is this thing valuable, not valuable? Um, and then the other
piece that really makes this, um, phenomenal is you audit your energy at the end of those 15 minutes.
Did that task light you up? Did he give you more energy or did it drain your energy? Do you not
like doing that thing? So drive to the office. Um, you know, I'm going to do email, email, boom.
I'm going to highlight that red, that drains my energy sales call. That actually gives me energy
because I love talking to people, team training. That gives me energy driving to the office. Um,
that drains energy unless I'm going to say, okay, tomorrow when I drive to the office,
I'm going to actually drive to the office and use my car as my university. I'm going to like be
listening to the digital landlords trainings. I'm going to be like learning while I'm driving,
drive to office. We'll do and learn. Boom. Now this value just went up and I enjoy it now. Okay.
So, um, this is the time and energy audit.
You audit your time and your energy. And what happens is you do this for a week and then you
start noticing all the things that are red and drain your energy and that are $1 signs.
And all of those things are the things that you see. How the heck can I stop doing that
and pay someone my buyback rate or less to do that for me? And now you have the exact
things you want to hire for. Um, for example, my first hire that I ever hired was a content writer.
Why? Because that drained my energy and I could hire someone, $4 an hour, $5 an hour to do that
for me. And I'm like, why am I spending 10 hours a week writing content? It makes no sense. Right.
Why next thing was building websites. Why am I building websites? So does that make sense?
Everybody, any questions so far? I guess in the chat, like put any takeaways, like what do you,
it's not what's taught, it's what's caught. So like, what do you guys catch in? Like what,
what so far is your biggest takeaway in the chat? Like teach each other, share that.
That when, uh, when you're doing the energy and time audit, do you, you write down,
I've done this before, but I haven't really done it as specific as you, which is like
drive to the office, like every single thing. Um, how do you, when it's stuff like that, do you like,
okay, let's say that you hate driving to the office. You hate, uh, you know, going and getting
lunch because both those things kind of like suck your energy and they're not really, I mean,
they're not providing money. They're just taking money. How do you get like, have you considered
hiring somebody or different solutions for that? Like, let's say driving to the office, what do you
do in that situation? You're like, okay, maybe I can't hire somebody, but I can start working from
home. Or you start thinking outside the box like that. Like what are some solutions to it instead
of just hiring or I'm talking about the things maybe outside of the business tasks, but that
you still have to do that are draining your energy.
That's an awesome question. Um, I think the first step is being aware, right? Like the first thing
that I would say you want to be problem aware. So the time and energy audit makes you problem
aware. And when you're aware and you write it down, then your brain starts working on it. And
you're like, how could I use my time more effectively? People that make millions and
millions of dollars a year, use their time much more effectively than people that make
$50,000 a year, right? So if we can look at how we're spending our time, this is actually super
eye opening. Like the first time I did this, the way I spent my time, the way I thought I spent my
time wasn't actually how I spent my time. So like, I challenge you guys to actually do this and
you'll realize like, whoa, I spend way more time than I thought, um, doing content writing or
building websites or these things that if it's on a computer, you can hire someone around the
world to do it. Um, and this will open your eyes. One thought on that with it's, it's not necessarily
hiring a VA from, from online jobs, but if you guys are like sitting at your house and you're
like, well, it's time for me to get lunch and you're driving to go get food because you want
to save $5 from a door dash fees. You guys are being very, very short-sighted because you can
literally spend, I can order Chipotle. You could count to 12. I can order it in like 12 seconds
and it would show up at my door and I saved like 45 minutes a day. And yes, instead of my Chipotle
bowl being $8, it's like 18 with delivery fee in the tip, but like the cost me 10 bucks. I just
bought 45 minutes of my time for $10 and it doesn't take me off task. I don't get stuck in
traffic. I don't get caught by my buddy. That's like, Hey bro, let me pick your brain, you know,
and you're not have to be rude. And then you get distracted. So it's the same concept, even though
you're not necessarily hiring a VA in the Philippines, you're hiring a door dash person
and it's costing you 10 extra dollars every day, but that saves you so much time. So just a thought.
That's awesome because it's not just employees, right? It's how it's like, you want to design
your life and to be aware first, you need to know how much your time is worth and then you need to
know how you're using your time. Time is the most precious resource, right? Like how are you using
it? So when you're thinking about that, like the reason I want to show you guys this is the way
is the way you spend your time isn't how you think you spend your time. Generally, we think
that we are much more effective than we actually are. So this is massively eye opening. So I
challenge you guys to do this. Okay. The third piece that'll kind of bring this all together,
it's called the buyback loop and it looks like this. Here we go.
It looks like this.
An arrow right there. So what happens, there's three steps. You audit your time with the time
and energy audit. You transfer the low value and energy draining things,
transfer to another person, to AI, like Nick's thing, DoorDash, like you transfer those things
to buy back your time, to get your energy where you want it. And then you fill, you fill your time
with more things that light you up that are green and are four dollar signs more valuable.
And it's a continuous cycle. You audit, transfer, fill, audit, transfer, fill, and you just spiral
upwards. And the momentum comes from the fill. Like you have to fill your time with things that
are more valuable than you used to do. And that's why it's so powerful. So this, this kind of
connects it all. And what happens is right here, this is called the pain line right here. And what
happens, people, you won't grow into pain if it is uncomfortable or, you know, you're not going to
make more sales calls. You're not going to grind harder if you know that that's just going to add
a ton of stress to your life. But what if you know that growing, adding monthly recurring revenue
to your business doesn't make you have to work more and more and more, but you have like the
ability to transfer and fill and you're making more money doing things, doing more of the things
that you like doing. So that kind of connects it all here. You have your buyback rate, you know
what your time is worth, and then you look at how you're spending your time and the energy it gives
you. One thing I haven't said yet either is over time doing these time and energy audits,
you'll realize, oh, I have more energy in the morning or I have more energy at night and then
structure your day accordingly. You know, if you have high value tasks that light you up,
do those when you have a lot of energy and like, you know, use your, your being tuned with your
body and like, no, okay, here's my energy. And then you'll be able to produce better work and
organize your day accordingly. So doing that, and then using this, it's called the buyback loop,
using the buyback loop to audit your time, transfer these low value, energy draining things
to other people. And then the key, the ticket, and people always get this wrong, is they fill
their time with social media, or they fill their time with like, stupid stuff that doesn't push
the needle forward. They fill their time, you know, like, time will expand, and you'll just
take like three hours to do something that you could do in 15 minutes. So the key is fill your
time with these things that are high value that you like doing. And then you build a life that you
you never want to retire from you build a life that you love. So yeah, is that making sense
for everybody or any any questions? Throw them in the chat. There's a couple questions I want to
mention, I want to give you this fun, this really extreme example. So I have a buddy.
He is a real estate agent. And he's been for as long as I've known him since about 2018,
this guy makes like, he makes over seven figures in commissions as a real estate agent, which is
very, very impressive, right? It's very difficult to find anyone that can make a seven figures
outside of owning their own business. And yeah, technically, you own your own business is real
estate. This guy's in St. George, Utah. He's not in Hollywood. He's he's makes he's mixed seven
figures doing real estate. This guy's a machine, dude. He's on the phone, I think like four hours
a day just cold calling. And I remember we used to do this meet, we'd meet like once a week have
lunch, like a group of us. And he was like, Yeah, I'm thinking about like, how do I can save time
and how I can because he makes money when he's on the phone, like that's it. And so what he did is
he bought a Sprinter van, he wrapped it with his logo to you know, whatever. And then he set up an
office inside the Sprinter van so that when he's on his way to showings, he can be dialing while
he's on his way to showings. And I was like, dude, that's so gangster. That is so next level that
he's even worried about the 15 minutes in between showing so he can be on his computer and making
those extra five phone calls, which I thought was pretty dang sweet. And sure enough, about a year
and a half later, I noticed his Sprinter van around town like he actually did it. He actually
freaking did it. So that's the kind of an extreme example. But one more thing I want to add.
It's kind of like, what Zach saying is super important about filling the time because it's
like, I don't remember, dude, I think maybe probably one of your missionaries, when we used
to teach people like, hey, if you're going to remove this bad habit, you have to fill it with
something else. Otherwise, it's like a hole, and the hole is going to be filled. So you got to
fill it with something good, or it's going to get filled with something not as good. So make sure
that you're not just leaving these empty gaps. We all know those people that go to the gym for
three hours, and you can get the gym done in 45 minutes to an hour. You don't need to be there
three hours. I don't care who you are. You don't need to be there three hours. An hour is plenty.
So I think that's super, super valuable. One thing I want to ask, Zach, how often do you recommend,
or do you personally do time and energy audits? Is it quarterly, monthly,
once a year? What's your go-to? And then we'll get into some of the questions everyone has.
Yeah, awesome question. I would say quarterly, once you've kind of gotten a good routine,
when you start this out, do like, start now and do it for two weeks, and then adjust. You're going
to make a lot of quick adjustments, and then do another one a couple weeks later, and a couple
weeks later until you feel like you have a good flow. Once you have a good flow of how you're
spending your time each day, and your routine, and it's dialed in, then you can go to quarterly.
But if you ever, the general thing is whenever you feel like, oh man, you know when you have
that feeling bogged down, or you're not stoked on what you're doing, do another time and energy
audit, and figure out why. Figure out why you're not completely stoked on your life.
Because you should be. You're a business owner. If you're doing it right, if you're owning your
business in the right way, we should be like the happiest people on earth, because we own our time.
We can work from anywhere. It's awesome. We can use the money the company generates to live the
best life we want to live, and keep making more money at the same time, if we do it right. So
that's kind of my thoughts on that. So you would recommend everyone
two weeks, go do a two week energy. Are you doing this on weekends too?
Oh yeah, yep. And I actually have like, I made it into a Google Sheet, so if anybody wants that,
just like direct message me, time and energy audit, and then I'll send you a link. You can
make a copy of mine, and you know, do it in the Google Sheet. But honestly, it's as simple as
this. You can just do it in a notepad, and just write it. Super cool, super easy. But
let me stop to share here too. You're good. I'm going to write direct message Zach Powell,
time energy audit to get his Google Sheet. And yeah, the other thing though is, I guess that's
just all of that is for the mindset, right? People have issues hiring because they're like,
I can do it, I can do it. It's just human nature. Like you were saying, we all do it, we all hold
on to things too long. But when we look at the numbers, we look at our buyback rate. Oh, shoot,
my time is worth $100 an hour. Now I can hire someone $25 an hour or less, man, I can do,
I can hire someone at that rate to do almost everything I do, right? And you upgrade your
life. And now you're doing way more effective stuff. So doing those three things and helping
those all come together in your mind will give you the confidence and realize it's actually dumb
for me to not hire. And that's what it usually takes for people to get to the point where they
start hiring. And then the issue becomes people are terrible at hiring. And I know we're running
short on time. But the next thing is like, how do you hire? And so I have like a full hiring
playbook of how I get a ton of applicants and dwindle them down automatically without taking
a lot of time to find awesome people to add to my team. So if anybody wants like my hiring
playbook, what I do, just direct message me like the word hiring, and I'll shoot you the link,
I have like a Google Doc of my process. So maybe I'll put that in the chat. But
I'll put it real quick. I'll put Zach for the hiring playbook. And he put this together guys,
for time's sake. And also because he's he's done this a lot. DM Zach Powell for hiring playbook.
Okay. All right. So you don't mind getting blown up?
Yeah. Yeah, it's fine. Everyone can just DM me like I love helping you guys we can
chat whatever. But the biggest thing is like with hiring, most people don't get enough applicants.
That's the number one issue. They don't have a big enough pool of people applying for their jobs.
So then they end up with like a couple applicants and they just pick one and hire someone not good.
So you want a lot of applicants. This is what the hiring playbook shows and shows my process for
getting a ton of applicants and then automatically dwindling those down to the best ones. So it
doesn't take a ton of your time, but you effectively get all the best ones in a group. That's the other
thing people do wrong is like they waste too much time trying to hire. And then it's a pain. And
that's why they don't upgrade and, you know, hire and transfer and fill very well is like it takes
so much time. So my playbook like makes it easy to automatically dwindle it down. And then the third
thing is like they end up with subpar employees because their hiring funnel is so thin, right? So
thick hiring funnel. Now you have the cream of the crop, way better people. When I first started
hiring, I made a lot of bad hires. Now almost every single hire is phenomenal because they align
so well. Like I have this huge pool and they align so well. And I just add phenomenal people to my
team time after time after time. So you want my playbook for how I do that? Just message me hiring.
I'll send it to you. Message me if you want the time and energy audit. These have been like
huge things for me to take it to the next level. And like not just financially because at one point
I was making a lot of money, but kind of hating life. Then I started making more money and loving
life more because of these things. So if you want to build a business that you never want to retire
from, that's how you do it, which is fun to think about. A couple of questions that were a little
more specific. Luke Hill has a question. How do you trust VAs with things like cPanel to build
out the site? Because it sounds like he's using WordPress. I know that like on Weebly and stuff,
you can give limited access. And I know you use Duda, but how do you deal? Let's just make it a
more general question. How do you hire or trust VAs and stuff with a little more sensitive
information? I think most tools will allow you to give limited access. I don't use WordPress,
but I've used it a teeny amount to know that you're talking about WordPress. Any thoughts on that?
Yeah, awesome question. Just as with anything, you build trust over time. So when you hire someone
through the hiring process, you've gained trust. And now you have your onboarding, right? You
should have an onboarding sequence of video recordings of yourself doing things and training
them. Video recordings of you training your team, they go through these things. And as you work with
them, you build trust. They start trusting you as the owner, someone that's going to pay their
salary, someone to work for that you're going to invest in them, care about them, have a good
company to work at, they're going to build trust in you. And you're going to build trust in them.
You're going to see how quickly they respond in Slack. You're going to see how quickly they do
things. You're going to see the quality of their work very quickly. And so like Nick's saying,
you can give them the all back access. And then over time, as you build trust, you give them more.
You know, now I have an assistant I've worked with for over two years. I just give her my
passwords to everything. We have like 100% trust. Yeah, yeah, she could rob me and steal
a couple thousand bucks. But it's like, yeah, she lost her job. Would you steal from your boss
thousands of dollars? No, probably not. Because you would lose your job. Are they going to steal
hundreds of dollars from me? No, because then they're going to lose their job. Like, it's just,
that's like another mental barrier that people have is like, I can't give this because I don't
trust the person will give them things that they can't mess up. Or like if they mess up,
it's low. It's like low, what do you call it? Low? Yeah, yeah, it's it's it's low. Yeah, low,
low risk, basically. Yeah, low risk. That's the risk. That's the low risk. That's what you want.
And then just build and give them more and more and more. So one thing, awesome question. It's
another mindset thing. One thing too, from our training, we've had Joe Jonas, the founder of
onlinejobs.ph on like twice. And I remember that he said, like he has employed his VA's have access
to literally everything, including his bank, including his credit cards. But what's so
interesting is that in the Philippines, this is such a cultural thing. There you're people that
mean, yes, there's going to be some bad people, but people that are on that site, for the most part,
like it's culturally unacceptable to basically ruin your boss or go backstab or not be loyal.
Like loyalty is a big thing in the Philippines. One of the reasons it makes such a good place
for VA. So I've personally never had any bad experiences in terms of like, I've never even
had a VA from the Philippines try and do content that's been plagiarized, which is still a bad
thing, but it's low on the totem pole of like offensive, illegal activity. I've never even
caught anyone doing, you know, plagiarized content. So I don't think it's something you
should super have to worry about. And I also remember in, I remember in a four hour workweek,
Tim Ferriss talking about when he was building a supplement company, when he used to give his VA's
like, basically they would be able to make decisions at anything below a hundred dollars.
So you have to, at some point guys, you have to relinquish control. If you think you're going to
control every aspect of your business forever, then you're not going to grow. It's the exact
saying. It's a mindset thing. And it's a limiting belief because you, you know, and this is one of
the things I heard really quick is we give ourselves as business owners, as entrepreneurs,
you know, we give ourselves slack when we fail because like, well, we learned a lesson,
but we don't give our employees that same slack. Sometimes we expect them to be a hundred percent
perfect. And like they're humans, they're going to mess up. They're going to forget to do this and
that. You have to expect that it's not going to be perfect. They're not going to do, they're not
going to, you can't expect them to carry a hundred percent as much as you because they don't own a
hundred percent of your business. But that's not the goal. You want to get somebody that can do it
80% or better as good as you. And then you hire it out. That's, that's the game. That's the entire
game. So real quick, couple of questions. Jason Adams says, this is why I use Instacart grocery
shopping is low value energy sucking and time consuming. Jason, that's because you've never
been to a Harman's. Just kidding. But I do love, I do love, you know, it's funny thing about me,
and this is one thing we could know. If you have something that's on your list, it's like
low value, but it's high energy. Those are things that you could keep and just kind of
chalk up to like they're your hobbies. Like for me personally, depending on the grocery store,
I don't mind going in grocery store sometimes going into produce. Like it kind of, I kind of
like it. I'm kind of weird like that. But I also know like my dad, if you catch him in a grocery
store, dude, the earth ending tomorrow, like he's done. He's not doing it. Right. So yeah,
that's just that's your investment quadrant, things that light you up, but are low value.
You want to do those things that you're investing in those. It's not your production quadrant, but
you're investing in those things and delegation quadrant, low energy, low money, like get those
off your plate for sure. And dude, I have no problem doing those kinds of things after hours.
I'm not going to do that in the middle of the day, obviously. Nick Kudlick from St. George says,
amazing read, how to buy back your time by Dan Martell. Yes. Phenomenal book. I know you
really like that book, Zach. A lot of these concepts are from that. Jason said he had a
seven figures in recurring revenue as a corporate employee in the investment industry. Then he quit
and started over. Yes. I remember that dude. And good on you, dude. Life's too short. He also said,
Dr. J weightlifting is a waste of time is a book. And he said, dude is jacked over 50 years, 50 years
old too. So check that out. Um, Luke says Kroger has saved so much of my time with delivery. There's
no fee for delivery. It makes no sense to drive. Beautiful. I agree. A hundred percent. So takeaways,
if you want to get the plate, the, the Google doc that Google sheet that Zach's put together,
DM Zach, if you want to get the playbook, the hiring playbook that Zach's put together,
DM Zach, go blow up Zach's DM. Uh, Zach's one of the only people that doesn't mind. You can go
blow him up. He's, he's obviously he's got limited time, but he's kind enough. You guys message him.
He'll send you those things and walk you through it. Um, any last thoughts you want to end with
before we, we end this, uh, stream Zach. Yeah. One last thought is it doesn't really click for
people. Sometimes this helps it click is you look at Amazon, Google, Microsoft,
the difference between those companies and your company is they have thousands of people,
tens of thousands of people pushing their company forward every day. That's why they're making so
much money. They have thousands of sales reps, thousands of programmers, thousands of people
pushing them forward, pushing forward. Of course they're going to win and make tons and tons of
money. If you only have you pushing you forward, you're just living in the slow lane. Why not hire
someone? And there's people can actually do specific things of your business way better than
you. You think you're going to be a better website builder. You think you're going to be better at
SEO. You think you're going to be better at sales. Even you're not, there's people better at that
thing than you. You just got to find them and set them loose. And now you're going twice as fast,
three times as fast. You have all these people, you become more like Amazon. So that's what needs
to click. Why is Amazon, Google, Facebook, why are they such big companies? Tens, even hundreds
of thousands of people are pushing them forward. Is it just you pushing you forward? Why don't you
enroll someone and push yourself forward way faster? And at the same time, not just do it
to make money and stretch yourself out, but build it right where now your life's awesome
and you're doing things that light you up and make you a ton of money day after day. And it's a
continuous upward spiral. That's the life that I want to live and I invite you guys to live too.
So if you want help with it, just let me know. Happy to chat about it. Beautiful. Zach Powell,
appreciate you, bro. Also, I know Zach does a bunch of stuff. Do you want to jump on?
What's your website? Let me just drop it in here.
ZachPowell.co.
Z-A-C-K-W-E-P-O-W-E-L-L.CO.
Yep. Yeah. I share like my Stripe page and like points of learning through my growth. It's like
a seven minute video and then another video about what I'm doing. But yeah, check it out.
Probably get some good insights. Zach Powell, thanks for jumping on, dude. I'm always a walk
away, edified, excited, pumped. And I appreciate you being on and everyone else I know is as well.
So we'll have you on again soon. And guys, message or DM Zach for those, the playbook,
the sheet, and then if you want to check out his website as well. But anyway, thanks, bro.
Thanks, Nick. That was fun, man.
Hey, talk soon, bro. See you.